il était en cavale suite à des
contentieux avec les services de l'état
concernant son exploitation agricole
jérôme la ronce 37 ans finit
dramatiquement sa fuite dans un petit
chemin de terre
car au moment de l'interpeller deux
gendarmes se sentant menacé par son
véhicule qui arrivait sur eux ont fait
usage de leurs armes
jérôme succombera dans sa voiture un an
après un militaire de la gendarmerie est
poursuivi pour violences ayant entraîné
la mort sans intention de la donner
mais la famille de l'agriculteur a le
sentiment que le dossier s'enlise elle
critique le déroulement de la
reconstitution qui s'est déroulée le 10
novembre
le fait que l'on n'ait pas fait une
remise en situation selon selon les
éléments de l'expertisé balistique c'est
à dire selon les données balistique 10
collection il n'y a pas eu tir de face
puisqu'il n'y a pas d'impact sur le
véhicule de phase dès lors que gendarme
soutient qu'il a fait ses deux premiers
tirs de face book xla possible pour
faire une reconstitution à partir des
éléments balistique
ça n'a pas été fait pour la famille la
thèse de la légitime défense ne tient
pas elle se bat pour de nouvelles
expertises et a déposé un recours devant
la cour d'appel de dijon contre les
juges d'instruction ces derniers ayant
refusé une demande d'actes
complémentaires je ne sais pas si on
arrivera à rendre justice à jérôme je
sais pas je juge aujourd'hui j'en suis
pas convaincu malheureusement si la
justice peut paraître lente elle compte
pourtant bien clôturer rapidement celui
ci sous réserve du règlement du dossier
c'est à dire de la vie qui va être
donnée tant par le procureur que par les
juges d'instruction la clôture de
l'instruction pour arriver d'ici l'été
voire l'automne et ensuite une décision
sera prise soit sur des poursuites soit
d'ailleurs sur l'absence de poursuites
un non lieu le rêve de l'avocat du
gendarme ayant mortellement touché
jérôme la rose il l'espère pour que son
client se reconstruire le gendarme
stanhope qui alors vais peut-être faire
hurler dans les chaumières mais tant pis
j'assume c'est à l'homme qui est détruit
psychologiquement il est détruit
psychologiquement parce qu'il a
malencontreusement donner la mort parce
que les circonstances ont été telles ou
le ta ble ment et ne pouvaient pas faire
autrement que de donner la mort et c'est
un homme qui détruit la sphère la ronce
comme certains l'appellent est un
dossier complexe qui ne laisse pas
indifférent dans le monde paysan
un comité de soutien existent même ils
se mobilisent régulièrement pour
demander comme ils l'affichent que
mémoire et justice soit rendue pour
géraud